week of january 18th to 24th the
seven-day average of
new hospital admissions of patients with
coca-19
also decreased by 15 to nearly
uh 13 000 per day however
over 78 000 patients were hospitalized
with coca-19 as of january 24th
419 827 deaths
have been reported since january 22nd
2020.
during the week of january 19th to
january 25th
the seven-day average number of deaths
decreased
by 4.9 to 3 113 per day
and while these data are trending
downward is a good sign
the number of deaths reported in a day a
single day during the outbreak
was reported on january 20th the peak
number
of 4 383
deaths though i am encouraged by these
trends
our case rates remain extraordinarily
high and now
is the time to remain vigilant if we
continue on the current trajectory
the cdc most recent national ensemble
forecasts
predicts that 479 thousand
to 514 000 covet 19
deaths will be reported and by february
20th 2021.
i know this is not news we all want to
hear but this is something
we must say so we are all aware but if
we are united
in action we can turn things around
continuing to expand
safe effective vaccination is key to
ending the cog19 pandemic and bringing
our
country back to health daily vaccine
doses administered continued to rise to
more than 1.6 million doses per day over
the past week
over 23.5 million doses of coca-19
vaccine have been
already administered this includes 3.4
million
million people who have already received
their second dose
i want to take a moment here to
emphasize that the covid19 vaccines are
safe and they work and this is backed up
with data that i would like to share
with you
last week the cdc released an mmwr on
severe adverse events
most notably anaphylaxis for those
received of the moderna vaccine as well
as the pfizer vaccine
based on our most recent data there we
found that there were 2.1
cases of anaphylaxis per million
administered doses of moderna
and 6.2 cases of anaphylaxis per million
doses administered of pfizer
let me be clear these are rare treatable
outcomes
and the cova 19 vaccines are safe
it's also important to put this into
context the risk of getting sick with
coven 19 are much
higher than the risk of allergy or
anaphylaxis from the vaccine
in the u.s sadly approximately 16
500 people for every 1 million who are
diagnosed with covid will die
and while anaphylaxis can be scary there
are effective treatments and
patients generally do quite well it's
also important to note the mild side
effects
like pain where you got your shot
feeling feverish or tired
um and muscle aches after getting your
shot these are all
normal and expected part of getting the
vaccine especially the second dose
and these symptoms mean that your immune
system is revving up and the vaccine is
actually working
cdc is actively monitoring for safety
signals
associated with these vaccines and we
are committed to sharing those safety
data with you
as they emerge also last week
cdc updated guidance to reduce barriers
associated with returning for a second
vaccine dose on a specific date or when
circumstances change between a first and
second dose
there are two important updates that i
want to clarify
first in our updated guidance the cdc
still recommends that people get their
second dose
as close to the recommended interval as
possible
that would be three weeks for the pfizer
vaccine and four weeks for the modern
vaccine
however we also know that life can get
in the way
and that some of those doses may be
missed in the best time window
and in those various circumstances the
second dose may be given
up to six weeks or 42 days after the
first
second the cdc has reiterated that the
covet 19 vaccines are not
interchangeable however it's also true
that an extremely rare circumstances
people may not simply remember or have
documentation of which first dose they
received
in these extremely rare situations we
have said that any available mrna cova
19 vaccine may be administered
as the second dose if people are unaware
of which first dose they received
and that would be at least 28 days after
their first
i also know that there are concerns
about variants
viruses mutate and we have always
expected that variants would emerge and
we have been looking for them
the variants have been identified
recently seen to spread
more easily they're more transmissible
which can lead to
increased number of cases and increased
stress on our already taxed
health care system in the united states
308 cases of b117 variant that
originated from the uk
have been confirmed in 26 states as of
january 26th
we also identified this week our first
case of
the p1 variant in the united states in
minnesota
to date no cases of the b1351 variant
that was first detected in south africa
has been identified in the u.s cdc is
committed to working with international
and
state and local partners and increasing
surveillance
to monitor the situation and share as
soon as we learn more
the emergency the emergence of variance
underscores
the need for public health action first
get vaccinated when it's your turn also
some people may need help getting
vaccinated please consider helping your
neighbors
and loved ones schedule or travel to
their appointments
second wear a mask practice social
distancing
and wash your hands and finally now is
not the time
to travel but if you must be safe
and follow the cdc guidance this
includes wearing a mask
as well as testing and the quarantine
protocol
please do your part to get cases down
by simply taking these actions
thank you i will now turn it over to dr
fauci who will share some scientific
updates
a bit about therapeutics um
in therapeutic doctor yeah
i believe your audio just came on so if
you could come back to the beginning
uh and start again that'd be great i
believe
your audio just came on so if you could
come back to the beginning
uh and start again that'd be great
in other words nobody heard anything
from me is that correct
okay well i said a lot of really
of concern that dr welinski mentioned
when you think in terms
of therapeutics you think in terms of
therapeutics for advanced disease
and therapeutics for disease but also
buried in that is targeting the virus
itself
versus targeting the aberrant
inflammatory responses that often are
the source
and the cause of the morbidities
and mortalities that we see with this
particular disease
so first if you look at the therapeutics
for moderate advanced disease
one of the ones that have shown clearly
to be very efficacious
is dexamethasone in people who are
hospitalized
who are on ventilators or have high flow
oxygen requirements it is shown to
significantly diminish the 28-day
mortality
there have been another a group of
studies such as varacinamide and rem
destiny
which have received an emergency use
authorization
moving over to the left-hand part of the
slide there are a number of
interventions that have been used for
more early or moderate disease for
example
rem desevier which is a direct antiviral
has received fda approval
and a variety of monoclonal antibodies
have also received
emergency use authorization as have
convalescent
plasma other antivirals hyperimmune
globulin
and things like anticoagulants are
currently in clinical trial
one comment about things like monoclonal
antibodies and convalescent plasma
since they are giving antibody to
someone
who would need a direct antiviral effect
of the antibody
it is best to use it early before
individuals actually have had the
opportunity to progress
and that's what we're going to be seeing
in the future is an attempt to as early
as possible
get these interventions to the patients
uh
in their particular state hopefully as
outpatients if we can logistically get
that done
we can move on to the next slide and
that is
vaccines as many of you know now
the federal government has been involved
either in the development
of and or the facilitation of the
testing
of a number of vaccines that represent
three separate platforms shown on this
slide is what we all know is the
extraordinary efficacious
and safe results of the moderna and the
fisa bioentech product with 94 to 95
percent
efficacy and a good safety profile both
having received
an eua what we're looking at closely now
is others that you see on the slide
johnson astrazeneca
and novavax which are in various states
of trial of particular importance that
you'll be hearing about
likely within the next few days to a
week
are the results from the onsen j and j
trial and the reason they're important
it relates to some of the things that dr
wolenski said
and that is it's a phase three trial
with a different platform
a human adenovirus vector but it is
going to be looking at efficacy
not only in the united states but also
in south africa
and in brazil so we will get a good
feel from those i hope i believe we will
we'll let the data
speak for itself but what we will see
was the relative efficacy against the
wild-type
virus that is predominantly in the
united states
as well as the south african uh
isolate which in fact is something that
we will be able to get a feel for
the efficacy there so we'll have some
comparative efficacy
which will inform us on where we would
go
if the eventuation occurs that we do
have that particular lineage that would
take
a sense seat itself in the united states
so let me move on to the last slide
because that relates
to what i said dr walensky gave you a
good feel
for the distribution of the various
lineages
the 117 which is in the uk the 351
south africa which i just mentioned and
the p1 in brazil
she mentioned about the increased
transmissibility and the likelihood of
an increase
actually in some lethality in the
b117 the important question that people
ask
is what is the impact on both monoclonal
antibodies
and on the vaccine induced
antibodies related to the vaccines that
we are currently
distributing now when you're looking at
the 117 namely what we refer to as the
uk variant what we're seeing is a very
slight if at
all impact on vaccine-induced
antibodies and very little impact on
anything else so we are covered
with that things get a bit more
problematic
when you go to the 351 or what we're
seeing as the dominant one
in south africa because in that regard
there is a moderate diminution namely a
multi-fold diminution
in the in vitro neutralization
by vaccine-induced antibodies however
and this is an important however
it still is well within the cushion of
protection
so you could diminish the
vaccine-induced antibody efficacy
by a few fold and still be well
within the protective range of the
vaccine and that's the reason why
you've seen announcements that actually
the vaccines that we're using are still
effective
however given that as a a fact
now we have to be concerned looking
forward
at what the further evolution of this
might be
now i want to make one mention about the
monoclonal antibodies because they are
more seriously
inhibited in the sense of impacting on
their efficacy
by this south african strain that's the
reason why there will be attempts
to develop even other antibodies that
might be able to avert
this particular problem so looking
forward what we plan to do
in collaboration with the companies is
to develop
what we would call alternative or boosts
that would use the same platform
but that would incorporate a particular
immunogen
that would address these particular
variants and for that reason we will
always want to be a step or two
ahead of what might be a problem in the
future so i'll stop there now and hand
it over
to andy slabid
thank you dr fauci bye audio one
yeah thank you dr fauci and also thank
you dr wolenski
uh the country is truly lucky to have
the two of you
uh leading the charge on both our
nation's best scientists and our
nation's best public health officials
i want to pick up where dr zwelinski and
fauci left off
public health and science i'm going to
talk about another topic
which is execution of the plan to combat
the coveted crisis
namely the strategy the progress and the
challenges
openly and transparently now to begin
i'd like to start with one of the core
pillars
of our plan and that is the equitable
health care access and outcomes for all
americans
so let me introduce dr marcela nunez
smith
who is head of the health equity task
force
to make some comments on where we stand
as a country
in a battle to make sure we get every
american
equitable access to medical care and
vaccinations that they need
great thank you so much sandy and that's
correct you know equity is absolutely a
foundational component of our national
plan
you know there's the moral imperative
it's simply the right thing to do
to ensure that those who are hardest hit
or at highest risk
have the opportunity to stay safe and
healthy through this pandemic
and there's also the science of it we
cannot beat this virus without making
sure we're executing a plan that works
for all communities
so we've committed to taking an equity
lens to every aspect of this pandemic
response
that includes minimizing the risk of
getting infected and for those who get
coveted
minimizing the risk of hospitalization
or death so that includes ensuring
access to ppe
testing treatments and vaccines
it also includes making it possible for
people to safely quarantine and isolate
and to monitor the impacts of long
covert
so from what the data show us we still
have a long way to go latino
indigenous and black people in america
are dying at high rates from coven 19
and folks in rural communities have case
and death rates
that continue to climb and they're dying
at higher rates than people in
metropolitan areas
so by race ethnicity sexual orientation
gender identity
you know disability geography based on
where you live
coven 19 is leaving a terrible imprint
on
far too many communities
next slide so the president took
immediate action
to combat covid 19 health equities
last thursday president bain signed an
executive order on ensuring an equitable
pandemic response and recovery and a key
part of his approach to ensuring equity
is through the kuvin 19 health equity
task force
so this task force is responsible for
providing specific recommendations to
the president
through the coven 19 response
coordinator from mitigating the health
inequities caused
or exacerbated by the covet 19 pandemic
and also for preventing these kinds of
inequities in the future
you know the task force will include
individuals with insights into these
groups
that have been hardest hit so their role
will be advisory in nature
but the president has asked them to make
some recommendations on a range of
issues optimally allocating coven 19
resources
by agencies and by state local tribal
and territorial officials
dispersing covet 19 relief funds in a
way that advances equity
you know ensuring effective culturally
aligned communication messaging
and outreach to our hardest hit
communities
and addressing ongoing health inequities
faced by coven 19 survivors
that may merit a public health response
it's going to be essential that we
collect data for the hardest hit
communities
and identify data sources that would
enable development
of short-term targets for pandemic
related actions
and address longer-term data shortfalls
and challenges to better prepare and
respond to future pandemics
so we will be announcing the members of
this task force soon
as president biden is adamant they hit
the ground running especially now as so
many people
and communities are disproportionately
hurting from this pandemic
and for the last slide you know finally
it's critical
everyone has equitable access to all of
the resources necessary
to make it through this pandemic and
that includes equitable distribution of
kubin19 vaccines to all communities
so all americans everyone in our country
should have the benefit of a safe
effective vaccine that can prevent them
from getting sick or dying from coven
19.
it takes intention and deliberate action
to advance equity in this vaccine
distribution process
so we're going to do that through a
series of important actions
we're leveraging data sources both from
government and other sectors
to find and remedy inequities you know
we're limiting
all out-of-pocket costs for vaccines
your ability to pay should not play a
role in your decision
of whether or not to receive this
vaccine we're removing structural
barriers to access and underserved
communities
we'll do this by making sure that it's
convenient
and accessible to get to vaccination
sites by increasing the clinical and
community-based workforce for outreach
education vaccination and wraparound
services you know we're working to make
sure that transportation and pay time
off are available
so people can make it out to get their
vaccine
we're going to increase and support core
venues of vaccination including
federally qualified health centers
and andy's going to talk about some of
our other venues for vaccination that
we're ramping up
but it will be important to make sure
vaccine is available for everyone and
oftentimes that will mean bringing the
vaccine right to people
so next we're already talking to states
about their pandemic plans and
strategies for equity
we're here to provide technical
assistance when needed
but when local health officials are
making great progress in equity
we're sharing some of those great ideas
with their peers around the country
and finally we're launching a robust
national public education campaign
to make sure people know about this
vaccine the facts and not the
misinformation
we want people to know that the vaccines
are safe and effective
we want everyone to be able to make
decisions with the best information
possible
and we're going to make sure that the
information comes to them in places and
in ways that are most likely to reach
them
it's critical this public education work
be very local in nature
critical that we in the federal
government support the relationships
that already exist between faith and
community leaders and their
communities so while there is no single
way to do this work there are best
practices that must define our approach
and supporting those best practices will
be our focus in the days and weeks to
come
so there's so much to do to get through
this pandemic and we want to make sure
all communities are cared for and
supported
along the way so with that i'm going to
turn it back over to you andy
thank you dr nunes smith and uh
look it's appropriate that i follow in
my report dr zwelinski
fauci and nunia smith uh very simply
because
it's important to send the message to
the public that the white house
respects and will follow the science and
the scientists will speak independently
and that our core values of science
public health and equity
drive our actions here at the white
house the president launched a national
strategy
just as he assumed office on the second
day
and at the heart of that plan it's the
most aggressive actions possible
to stem the pandemic and follow the
science
so dr wolinski spoke about the high
levels
of spread still in this country even as
they decline
dr fauci talked about the threat from
the new variants
dr nina smith spoke about
our difficulty and challenges in getting
access to vaccines all across the
country
so given those realities accelerating
the availability and the administration
of vaccines are all the more important
so it's been a busy seven days you've
seen us begin to execute our strategy
we set up a team began working with
states
and vaccine manufacturers launched
community vaccination centers
taken action to improve supply revised
travel restrictions and more
now i know that many americans are
anxious
and eager to get vaccinated i want you
to know we're taking this issue on
with incredible urgency and purpose
despite
not inheriting a fully developed
strategy or the infrastructure
to make vaccines readily available to
americans as quickly
as they need to be so far this week
we've been hitting our target of an
average of one million vaccinations per
day
necessary to meet the president's early
commitment
to administer 100 million shots in 100
days
now as you heard from the president this
week he is pushing us to view one
million
per day as the floor not the ceiling
to that end we are releasing more supply
activating fema and deploying
many more personnel in fact just this
week
fema announced that they had obligated
one billion dollars to support
state vaccination sites
now i want to step back for a moment and
put our vaccination plan in some context
to vaccinate every american over the age
of 16.
we are looking at a total need of well
over 500 million
doses of vaccines now
that assumes two shots for every
american 16 and older now i want to
pause and say that everything we're
talking about today
in terms of vaccines reflects the
vaccines currently on the market
that is a two dose regimen we are not
counting on things that are not
in existence today our plan will be to
make sure
that we prepare for as many
contingencies as exist
right now i want to level with the
public that we are facing
two constraining factors the first
is getting enough supply quickly enough
and the second
is the ability to administer the
vaccines quickly once they're produced
and sent out to the sites we are taking
action to increase supply
and increased capacity but even so
it will be months before everyone who
wants a vaccine
will be able to get one
now let me start with what's happened so
far
we've delivered 47 million doses
now we've gotten several questions on
this so i want to be clear
as you heard us announced yesterday any
stockpile that may have existed
previously
no longer exists our practice is to
maintain a rolling inventory
of two to three days of supply that we
can use to supplement any shortfalls in
production
and to ensure that we are making
deliveries as committed
but we are passing doses directly along
to states
very much in real time as they order
them
and we are confident that we will
receive the supply on a rolling basis
from the manufacturers to allow us to
continue to do so
now we know there are places in the
country with not enough vaccines
and at the same time there are places
with vaccines that they are not using
yet
this is a natural challenge states are
facing
and we will give them more visibility
into their forthcoming supply
and providing technical assistance that
will help them make sure to make
quicker use of these doses but i want to
emphasize an essential ingredient
to increasing the administration of
vaccines is passage of the american
rescue plan
which dedicates needed money
for vaccinators and for the
administration of vaccines
now let me take you through what we're
doing to increase the supply
so the president invoked the defense
production act last week
as a big first step to increase the
supply of vaccines
we're going to make sure that we get six
doses out of 500 vials
everywhere in america because that's the
potential
and we're going to do that by acquiring
something called
low dead space syringes i'm sure
everybody knows what low dead space
syringes are
i now do and yesterday
we announced a 16 increase in supply
flowing to states every week
for the next three weeks to a minimum
of 10 million doses per week that's good
news
but what's also important about it is it
gives states the visibility that they
have lacked
to know how many vaccines are coming in
so they can make commitments
to their partners in states and to the
citizens
and residents of their state so they
know when to expect vaccines to arrive
pfizer and moderna are committed to
delivering
a total of 200 million doses by the end
of march
with much of it coming at the end of the
quarter so it will accelerate
pfizer yesterday announced that they
think they can deliver
120 million doses this quarter
and as you heard from the president
yesterday
the united states plans to purchase an
additional 200 million doses
from moderna and pfizer this year
which will be sufficient to vaccinate
every american over the age of 16.
and we expect those doses this summer
this entire thing is an unprecedented
undertaking
we will run into anticipate
unanticipated issues
but our plan and the actions we're
taking in the days and weeks ahead
is to deliver on these commitments to
the public
finally we've also announced that we are
creating additional pass
to get americans vaccinated these will
include
standing up what we call community
vaccination centers
we are going to launch 100 community
vaccination centers this month
we will be also supplying more
we will be supplying vaccines directly
to pharmacies
we will be standing up mobile clinics to
reach hard to reach areas particularly
in for september this year not even
the most prominent scientists
in in this area
this leads you may say naturally
but it leads you can also say
unfortunately
you could say of course this leads to
many speculations
but all this speculations are hurting
the athletes in their preparations who
have already
to overcome the challenges in their
daily training and competition with all
the the restrictions they are facing
uh either in their country or when it
comes to to traveling
so there is a speculation about
cancellation about
about a plan b about everything
you know some even make the proposal to
postpone
the olympic games in he took it to
the year 2032.
uh i want to say good luck
if you would have to discuss this with
an athlete
who is preparing for the olympic games
uh
2021
there are some proposals to move it to
to another city
which uh everybody who knows about the
complexity of uh
olympic games is not is not possible
uh that
foreign
but as we all know that's just the start
we need congress
to provide money for additional
vaccinations
sites that provide for more uh
vaccinate tours so in order to
get all americans vaccinated we need
congress to provide
funds for vaccination we still do too
little testing in this country
we need to ramp up testing significantly
to need congress to fund
more testing uh in order to reopen
schools and businesses
and take care of people in congregate
settings
furthermore believe it or not we still
have shortages of ppe
and other critical materials we need
emergency funds
in order to make sure that we have those
materials
so those are just three of the key areas
that need to be funded by congress
in order for us to execute on the
president's national plan
maybe you can repeat the question for dr
wolinski and i'll hand it over to her
yes the question for dr valencia is
if how accurate is your data showing
that states and localities are using
only half the vaccine
supply and if that is not the real
picture then
what is the accurate picture that's a
great question
um we have a database that actually
looks at the vaccine supply
i want to literally that um you know not
all
vaccine that is sort of uh allocated or
delivered or whatnot is available
for inserting into people's arms and
that where in the pipeline
that is varies by the day of the week
whether it's available that singular day
we are working very hard and ensuring we
understand
exactly where the vaccine is on any
given day and the
reporting of the data is actually also
behind
so we're getting when vaccines are
reported rather than when they're
actually administered
so much of our work over the next week
is going to make sure that we can
tighten up the timelines
understand where in the pipeline the
vaccine actually is
and when exactly it is administered yeah
i want to make two points one most
states are getting better
at putting needles in arms and the
federal government
is beginning to support those efforts
through all the
vehicles that that andy described
in partnership with the states some of
what
is is the states are have right now is
inventory to do the very very important
second shot so i think it's important
that when you're
looking at states inventories that you
recognize that some of that inventory
is being held for the very important
second shot
which we all believe that everyone
should follow the fda guidelines that dr
whitby said earlier
so states are getting better the federal
government is ramping up its support
we've got a long way to go and
we're very committed to the 100 million
shots in the first 100 days
great let's go next to ed o'keefe at cbs
news
thank you all for doing this um a few
kind of questions about the defense
production act and the aspects of sort
of how the administration can
maybe hasten the production of vaccine
and related products
um regarding these new doses from modern
and pfizer
uh that y'all announced yesterday have
those two companies specifically told
you when
these extra 100 million doses will be
available i know
some administration officials said
yesterday over the course of the summer
modernist said third quarter of 2021
that's a broad range so i'm curious if
you can
sort of narrow that down and um now why
isn't it being used yet the dpa to
perhaps compel other companies
or even other pharmaceuticals to help
make already approved vaccines
so let's let's take it a question at a
time um andy
why don't you start with the dpa and
then also touch on the likely delivery
of the additional 200 million doses
great thanks for the question the
defense production act is a very
important vehicle for us
and we have an entire team that's
focused on how to maximize in speed
supply now at its first instance
getting the syringes and all of the
other ancillary capabilities necessary
to get americans
their vaccines is one of the core areas
we've identified 12 areas where the
president has authorized us
to use the defense production act
including masks
including more testing including many
spaces
to the very specific question of whether
or not a factory
can be retrofitted to mass produce
another vaccine that's something that's
under active exploration
as you can imagine it's not as simple as
walking in and flipping a switch
these are delicate processes very
sterile processes and have to be
you know done in a way that actually
completely works but we will not be
afraid to explore every option to get
more vaccines
to the public as quickly as possible as
for the timing of
the moderna and pfizer contracts you
know i think
look it is no secret that is our goal to
accelerate that as much as
possible uh to the extent that we run
into those
physical limitations we have to make
sure that that the vaccines
uh that are produced um are done the
right way
so that we can sign off and get them to
the states and get them to the public so
right
now that looks like sometime over the
summer
so hypothetically then what you're
saying is
you could you're exploring the
possibility of saying
again just hypothetically potentially
having someone like merck
produce the modern vaccine by using the
dpa to do that
well i don't want to i don't want to
talk about specific names per se
but i will say that we are exploring
every
possible option uh you know we do not
believe that in
a emergency crisis situation that we're
in that it is responsible
to just pick one path and pin our hopes
on that
obviously there are other vaccine
manufacturers that are submitting
emergency use authorization
applications there are other
manufacturers
that are not pursuing their own vaccine
and for all of those we will be looking
at ways to accelerate but when we make a
commitment to the public
we don't want to make a commitment to
the public based on things that have not
been accomplished
we want to make our commitment based on
the things that we know about today and
that's why we're talking
about through the course of the summer
we'll do everything
in our power of course to accelerate
that yeah i think yeah just to summarize
it
this is a national emergency 400 000
people have died
everything is on the table across the
whole supply chain
from the deadweight syringes to other
pharmaceutical companies
to anything we can do to increase the
vaccine supply
and the timing of the delivery is on the
table
and we will execute accordingly
great uh let's go to kristen welker at
nbc news
thank you so much couple of questions
just to follow up on
ed i just wanted to be very clear has
the president
actually signed the dpa and
can you speak to the timeline you raise
the issue of summer
and just so that we're clear on the
expectations by the end of summer
president biden said that he was
confident by the end of summer
uh 300 million people uh would
be vaccinated is that still your
expectation
and then can you speak to some of the
concerns that we've heard
from governors who have cheered this
announcement and say they welcome more
supplies they welcome more
vaccines but in the words of larry hogan
quote
we are going to need much more supply
are you able to meet what the governors
are asking for not just increasing it
in this first tranche but continue to
meet what they're asking for
so thank you for the question let me let
me speak to that first of all
i think it's important to clarify the
difference between 300 million
or 600 million vaccines being produced
in the process of getting that
across the country to providers and
pharmacies and community clinics and
into people's arms
there are many more challenges so what
we've talked about yesterday what the
president announced was a first step
namely to make sure we have enough
production making sure that
300 million people get vaccinated have a
lot
of a lot of other elements including
community conversations to discuss
people's concerns about vaccines as we
get into the
summer including making sure that to our
earlier points we are
getting every community access to
vaccinations so there is a huge process
which we are over to undertaking
to do this and so i don't want you to
hear that just because
they are will be manufactured and
produced by a certain date
that that is the same thing as taking
every step necessary to get them
to the public as for governor hogan's
comments
about wanting more vaccines we hear you
governor hogan and we couldn't agree
more
i would love to tell you that we
inherited a situation where there were
stockpiles and stockpiles
of vaccines sitting there that is not
the case
and it is our job to level both with the
governors
and with the public having said that
what we have been able to do
is make a commitment to increase by 16
percent
the amount of vaccines going out and to
provide three weeks
of visibility which will allow them to
plan better
and we hope to do our best to increase
and accelerate more vaccines
as we see them
great uh let's go to yamiche alcindor
pbs
hi thanks so much for taking my question
i have two questions the first is
here just for maybe for housekeeping i
just want to make sure how many
vaccinations are currently available
and what's left in the federal stockpile
is they're are we dealing with a finite
number of vaccinations or are they
coming in at a certain
i'm just kind of wondering if you could
talk through the numbers again and then
the second
question i have is what percentage of
vaccinations people that are already
vaccinated
it's coming back with racial and
ethnicity information because i'm
wondering
how we know who is getting what and how
you're gauging
um success and when it comes to the
people that are getting vaccinated
so so andy why don't you take the first
question and dr nunez smith ii please
yeah so today we've delivered 47 million
vaccines to states
um and we are committed to delivering
an additional 10 million per week for
the next three weeks to states
now we do not keep a stockpile
of a large number of vaccines uh we keep
a two to three day supply as a practice
just to account for variation in
manufacturing production
that's it the rest moves out to states
i think part of the confusion here is
there was a practice early on before we
were in office
of having a stockpile the president
elected
two to three days as andy said
of supply to deal with any unforeseen
situations
dr nunez smith great thank you and thank
you for that
question um so we are 100
committed to making sure that when it's
your
turn that you have access to the vaccine
and we know that
access in in many communities that have
been hard hit
might be a challenge you know to your
specific question around
race ethnicity data you know we are
making a call
to get better more consistent uh
data particularly around some of these
demographic points
and we see right now around 16 states or
so that are releasing
our race ethnicity data but it's true
that those data are incomplete
but it's not our only you know sort of
visibility into what's happening
the the cdc for example has a metric
around social vulnerability
you know many states are using that now
we encourage the use of equity metrics
such as that
as states are doing their mapping and
planning um so we can think about things
like
like neighborhoods and communities as
metrics and ways to track as well and
and where we're building our our equity
dashboard
right now and we'll rely on government
sources as well as uh sources of data
external to government
and could i just ask us a follow-up how
soon do you think you'll let the plan to
roll out vaccines to communities of
color will have real impact
i know we've talked about summer and and
other months for
the nation as a whole i wonder if there
are any estimates for
communities of color and vulnerable
populations
absolutely so you know that that work is
happening right now
so in states and localities you know
where
uh you know depending on on kind of
what's on the ground as far as
prioritization
but in those communities that have been
hard hit you know i say kudos to all
of the local health officials who are
making those pushes to get to those who
are over 75 you know who are in
affordable housing communities
who are bringing vaccine to people you
know in homeless
shelters so you know again who meet the
criteria for the prioritization and so i
think that's the key
is when we say you know everyone over a
specific age
is eligible that we're gonna have to
take an extra step
to get to some of the people who are
hardest to reach and that work is
already happening now
thank you and we're coming up on the top
of the hour so we have time for one more
which will go to alice park at time
you